[Music]
Tellus is a global leader in the
Telecommunications and the technology
industry originating in Canada they are
recognized for their Innovation and
ability to connect people businesses and
communities worldwide this is done by
using deep personalization and
understanding individual customer needs
to provide an exceptional customer
service
experience being a telecommunications
company they Embrace cuttingedge
technology such as Google Cloud cont
tech center AI CCI aai this enhances
customer interactions tailoring them to
individual needs in order to make them
intuitive seamless and
efficient let's see one way they used it
in the fast-paced world of corporate
retail seamless operations and
outstanding customer support are
Paramount when a corporate store
representative faces challenges timely
and efficient assistance is essential
especially during high volume periods
such as Black Friday where customers are
wanting to renew or purchase new
products and services that's where we
have been utilizing ccai insights part
of Google Cloud's contact center AI
Suite to understand key opportunities to
reduce unnecessary calls to our support
teams allowing our corporate store
representatives to focus on providing a
great customer experience by harnessing
the power of CC aai insights vertex Ai
and the advanced generative AI models by
Google my team has been able to decipher
the root causes behind support calls
transforming raw data into actionable
intelligence and allowing our enablement
teams to drive out inefficiencies in our
processes and reduce unnecessary calls
to do this we started by developing
topic models in the CC aai insights
platform for our corporate stores we
have five models that were developed one
for each line of business we support for
example this model is for Tellis
Mobility business and has 10 mutually
exclusive topics these models have all
been deployed to production and we use
CCI insights to classify new calls in
real time which helps Drive operational
decisions in addition to this we also
have all of the call transcripts topic
labels and metadata piped into big query
for further analysis in the next step of
this use case we leveraged vertex Ai and
Google gen AI models to delve deeper
into the root of the calls this is the
notebook and code utilized for this
in-depth analysis to start We Gather the
necessary data from Big query focusing
on data from three out of the five
models developed in insights
specifically we con trade on what we've
identified as low value calls such as
order troubleshooting which accounts for
over 50% of the total calls to the
support team next we engineered prompts
for the Google gen model to analyze the
calls this was an iterative process with
substantial effort given to defining the
context provided to the model with the
intent of improving the quality of
output and classification results our
objective was to discern whether calls
stem from technical issues or knowledge
gaps areas where immediate improvements
could be made upon completion of this
analysis we presented the results via a
looker dashboard engaging our Channel
care operations team together we
identified five key areas for Action
these actions will potentially reduce
the total call volume into our Channel
care Que by 25% on Black Friday weekend
and free up over 12200 hours of team
member time both in store and on Q and
will enable us to provide unparalleled
support to our customers during the next
high volume
period that was just one way tell us
uses gole gole Cloud's contact center AI
platform to understand key opportunities
and reduce unnecessary calls to their
support teams the insights from this
data helped reduce CHC Q call volume by
25% allowing their corporate store
representatives to focus on providing a
great customer experience to learn how
you can use the contact center AI
platform to reduce unnecessary costs to
your support team and provide better
more personalized service check out the
links in the description below
[Music]